and now great moments and unintended consequences
part one the money train the year 1862 the problem
well yeah sure but the other problem there's no
railroad connecting coastal elites the solution
pay rail companies for each mile of track
laid for a brand new transcontinental railroad
sounds like a great idea with the best of
intentions what could possibly go wrong while
congress has never been great at keeping
an eye on spending it's even worse during
the civil war with no one looking the union
pacific unnecessarily lengthened their route
adding miles of track and pocketing almost half
a million dollars after two and a half years of
construction the union pacific laid track all
the way from omaha to 40 miles outside of omaha
i choose to choose to screw taxpayers part
two burning cash the year 2012 the problem
an over-reliance on fossil fuels in northern
ireland the solution a subsidy for heat generated
from renewable sources sounds like a great idea
with the best of intentions what could possibly
go wrong well it turns out that the rate paid by
the subsidy was greater than the costs of the fuel
being used so the more wood pellets you burned the
greater your profit voila the cash for ash program
with farmers heating empty buildings just to
collect a paycheck the resulting fallout included
northern ireland's first minister refusing to
stand aside during any inquiry the deputy first
minister resigning in protest the dissolution of
the northern ireland assembly and the collapse of
the executive branch for almost three full years
not to mention a whole lot of taxpayer dollars up
in smoke part three all right fine we'll do the
cobra thing the year sometime in the 19th century
maybe not sure might not actually be true who
knows the problem the english colonial city of
delhi is infested with venomous cobras the
solution give money to anyone who brings in
a dead cobra sounds like a great idea with the
best of intentions what could possibly go wrong
it didn't take long for folks to realize that the
bounty paid for a dead cobra was greater than the
cost of raising a cobra what city officials
got wind of lucrative snake breeding farms
they repealed the bounty leading cobra farmers to
release their now worthless snakes into the wild
net result more cobras than ever a lot of wasted
cash and a book by some german guy with a title
that sounds straight out of gi joe while the
veracity of the cobra story is hard to pin down
there was a documented problem in hanoi under
french colonial rule only this time the issue
was rats with a bounty paid for every rat tail
brought to authorities it wasn't long before
colonial officials began to notice rats without
tails having been set free by rat catchers with
a basic understanding of economics but don't
worry we learned our lesson and it never happened
again fort benning georgia where the feral pig
population was out of control the bounty for
some forehead slapping reason was pigtails which
once again blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
more pigs they eventually discontinued the
bounty so don't worry everything's swine now
great moments and unintended
consequences good intentions bad results